could you talk about okay because this
confuses me okay oh my gosh this
confuses me femininity
because a lot of times when women use it
it's so Broad
and there's never any real concrete like
definition of it that that I've seen and
then I see all these femininity coaches
that just say get in your feminine
energy and I'm just thinking what the
heck does that mean and I sort of
understand what they're saying but a lot
of times the way it translates to me
just the way I think is a lot of them
doing nothing and then saying they did
something ooh so it's like a lot of
women will like that coach femininity
will be these masculine women that are
clearly masculine like I can see it like
I'm talking to you I'm talking it'll be
like these girls will come on the show
they don't cook they don't do any of the
tradition but they're just in their
feminine energy and
they might say that they cook but you
can just tell when a woman talks about
cooking if she actually Cooks because a
girl that actually Cooks will give you
more detail and like a girl that doesn't
will say like like very broad oh I cook
this or maybe like some rest a piece
she's seen her mom like you can just
tell so like what is femininity how do
you improve it
yeah what what actually is femininity
and what are that like how specifically
do you improve it you know this one it's
interesting that you say that we
actually talked about this on my last uh
Wives Club episode that's the other
Channel that I have but femininity is
one of those things where
there is a dictionary definition and I
looked it up but it's also one of those
things it's a little bit elusive because
it's hard to Define but you know it when
you see it right however there are a lot
of buzzwords going on right now we have
that soft life era but it's not
something that you put on it's who you
are especially when you're tested so you
remember when we talked about like I
know that
I struggle sometimes with tough topics
and so I have to remove myself get it
together and come back because I don't
want to have you know an emotional
response those are the times when you
have an opportunity to be you know
masculine and you choose not to
consistently so for me it's so good who
you are
when you're tested okay right so when
the kids are hungry and they're pulling
at your skirt and they're like Mommy can
we eat if them kids is probably not the
most feminine
right so you know we can work on that
but yes it's it's a buzzword that you
know if people say but they don't do
then they're not feminine because if
you're truly feminine I don't have to
tell you that I'm feminine you would
pick up on that
right so to me and the dictionary
definition is something about having the
qualities or the characteristics of a
woman and when we had our last episode
on the Wives Club I said you know for me
I really have been intentional about
studying men because I am a boy mom you
grew up between Brothers watching how
they act and doing the opposite so if
they come into a room and they're all
loud I bring my volume down I slow down
and I'm mindful of my gestures if they
take up a lot of space if they're just
like heavy you know stomping around then
I'm like oh okay and it is something
that I had to learn and we talked about
this a little bit yesterday with co-ed
schools and just kind of like being
around boys or any environment that
you're in you're gonna pick up on that
whether it's the corporate or whether
it's girlfriends that you know are a
little bit messy or whatnot so to answer
your questions so that I clearly
communicate you know being feminine is
the opposite of a man and I know things
have gotten Blended but I also believe
being feminine is being consistent and
being feminine is
um you know like I said when you're
tested when it's difficult but you still
maintain so how do you improve on that
um you seek it out and you get coaching
and you act on that coaching like I
shared with you I learned that I used to
have really masculine gestures I was a
little bit all over the place so you'll
see me kind of put my hands down and
clasp them together because I'm being
mindful of okay I want to be a little
bit more
um delicate and refined I notice when I
get loud I'll catch myself and I'll
lower my volume these are just things
that I've had to work on for other
people and I'm not joking it could be
swearing for you swearing wasn't an
issue for me but being loud was it could
be uh being gracious and generous to
people like I smile a lot and I'm
Pleasant it might be an area that
someone else has to work on because they
want to say you know what that's them
kids or whatever so being mindful
finding out the areas where you're
lacking because there are different ways
to be feminine there are different types
of it
um these are all things that I've
studied again for me it's an area that I
could kind of nerd out in but I think
what you said about taking one thing at
a time just at knowing it Kevin always
used to say self-awareness right not
saying I'm a 10 I'm average I know that
so I try to really over perform in other
areas and so you know a little bit
long-winded answer but I would just like
to encourage anyone that you can
definitely get better if it's something
that's important to you and femininity
is what men respond to because they
don't want somebody that reminds them of
themselves
do not be a feminist
I wrote this these under the wrong one
I gotta move this okay
I might have to ask you to Define that
one because that how feminist uh
definition it's changed and a lot of
times people hang what they want
something to mean on a certain word and
even things that might have started off
a little Noble now there's
Wild feminists
someone that wants women
that believes women are better than men
and say they say it's equality I was
gonna say because what I've heard is
people say we're equal you don't want
women and men to be evil and in a way
that that's part of the problem is they
think men and women are equal so they
one they they think men and women are
equal which we're not we're different
yeah and on top of that they also think
that women are better than men and they
might not say that in the definition but
you could certainly see it by the you
know the things they say like men are
trash yeah
um the the way feminists act in the
media and the issues that they support
that are often at the expense of men so
for example me too
you know it might have had good
intentions but what are the outcome
um so yeah that's that's what I would
say don't don't be a feminist yeah that
one so that one's a hard one as a boy
mom sometimes it's a visceral reaction
that I get because that Mama Bear kind
of comes up and you know I have heard
that I have heard women that I've worked
with basically say men are stupid
um you know you only need one parent you
don't need you know a man as long as
you've gotten one good parent and I
think that is it's so detrimental but
these are going to be the same people
that kind of wish they had a man when
times get hard in my opinion
that's the saddest thing where they
don't think
like I think going to a sperm bank and
just having a kid is cry I know someone
that did that she uh she she was
morbidly obese
she was in her 40s and she had twins
and and one of the twins came out like
their foot was messed up because and I
just remember thinking this this was a
horrible idea why didn't you just get
married yeah and I know this one is a
really touchy one for a lot of people
but we talked about this yesterday and
I'm just gonna say I think inherently
it's selfish because I want a child you
have to think about what life are you
creating for this child and you know
children get their identity from their
father you know I see it now we talked
about this yesterday I'm so glad that I
co-parent even though the marriage ended
my youngest is in boarding school he
goes to military school and my oldest
lives with his dad pretty much he comes
to visit me because at 15 he I mean he
has his he had his dad the whole time
but it is so important and um you know I
know people make decisions for what they
want but you know we talked about this
yesterday even if I would have loved to
um get remarried and have more children
I don't get what I want just because I
want it there are children that are
already here and my responsibility is to
finish what I started and if I'm so
fortunate to get married again and live
out my golden years then that is what I
get that is the hardest thing at times
like as women and I've even struggled
with this like understanding it's his
plan it's not your plan and so if he
wants to do it we can do it if not you
know yeah I got that yeah I mean like I
said you know we had um two boys back to
back and I asked my husband at the time
I said do you want to try for a girl do
you want three if he had said yes we
would have you know I would have been a
mom of three but he said no I just think
discounting men is is first of all this
is a human being that has you know
feelings and emotions and you know I
just as a mom this is a tough one for me
because I see what's out there and you
know I want I want everybody to win but
you know I do feel very strongly about
just completely discounting men just
because because if the tables were
turned
yeah
yeah it would be
huh
to not
set okay decided I'm just tired of these
words yes it's from the show partner
horoscope signs looking for a connection
energy
trauma toxic masculinity my truth oh my
gosh healing my narcissistic
ex-boyfriend my abusive ex-boyfriend a
great accusation with no evidence okay
I'm glad you said don't don't judge
um yeah but manifesting equals I do I
want to work but I want to do no work
and get the outcome as a woman we know
what your gender is I did too much and I
let him walk all over me equals I like
cheaters and toxic men and I will choose
them and be toxic as well and not admit
that I had any part to play except quote
unquote giving too much generational
trauma I make the same mistakes that my
parents make and I'm too dumb to learn
from their mistakes and instead I will
make the same mistakes but blame it on
them in my feminine energy men always
stare and approach me I will be
submissive for the right man men are
trash equals I take no accountability
for the negative part that I play or any
women play in our relationships he needs
to make six figures equals I have no
emphasis on character I don't need a man
but I want a man my ring needs to cost
this much Financial abuse I became
feminine I need a man to maintain me we
need to Vibe I feel like I am
traditional when I am single
oh my goodness are these quotes from
your show yeah just like talking to
girls okay almost all of them I
understand help me understand since we
were just talking about femininity I
became feminine because you can improve
you know I I understand where you're
coming from I may I may walk back this
one okay however I find that most of the
time when women say it it equals I did
no real work I made no real changes but
I say I am feminine oh just like poof
okay yeah I just I became feminine and
then I'll like break it down and I'll be
like okay so what what did you do to
become or they'll say I was Modern and I
became traditional so I'll say well what
did you do to become those things and
they'll have like
just word salad yeah no and no real
answers like you know if you're gonna
say I became look what you said was a
real answer I worked on lowering my
voice I used to do masculine manner
those are real answers and that actually
clarified
that actually clarified
you don't have to copy it better this is
better this is something better it's
important to me but yeah I mean again no
you actually clarified a lot of things
that um like I I honestly was so
confused when I heard it because I just
heard so much like fluff and garbage and
even like girls that I know that studied
femininity and would say I became
feminine had no real answers yeah and
then they would say oh I became feminine
but you're screaming at your your guy
how did you become feminine if you're
screaming at him right if you have that
response then you still have some work
to do because if you ask these same
women how did you get your cosmetology
license oh I had to study this amount I
had to take these mini classes I had to
do these many hours how did you become a
dentist how did you pick anything we can
walk you through all of the things that
we do to get what we want and goal of
you know how you show up in a
relationship requires just as much work
if not more and it's okay I'm actually
kind of proud to say you know I have had
to do a lot of work to go from that 50
50 mindset to being more of a support
system and I haven't arrived I still
have work to do but I've gotten a lot
better so
so is there any phrases we should add to
here that you've heard oh goodness so
you had the the trauma and the energy
um toxic let me know in the chat guys if
there's anything we missed that we need
to add
um
what Manish have you heard that one no
oh but I'll add it yeah
it's basically describing masculine
Behavior like there's something wrong
with it and it's not better or worse we
are different we're equally valued but
we are not equal and I think that's a
beautiful thing
I thought of another I need like I need
there's some phrase that girls use when
they won't be led by a guy and they're
like oh well I need the right man to
like I'll be submissive for the right
man I will be submissive for the right
man because
I in a way I understand where they're
coming I was gonna say yeah this one I
could unpack a little bit too but at the
same time that equals as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible